there are a few situations more
dangerous than entering a burning
building
thermoplastic fire helmets weighs
substantially less than other
Alternatives these helmets are one piece
of equipment that won't slow down the
rescue mission production starts with
the special blend of thermoplastic
pellets a vacuum pulls the pellets into
a hopper the pellets then flow into an
injection molding machine it melts and
molds the pellets into the shape of a
fire helmet
a robot retrieves the helmet and
transfers it to a cooling station
a worker then Clips off plastic that's
solidified as it flowed through a
channel and into the mold this unwanted
bit is called sprue
she wipes off fingerprints and inspects
the condition of the helmet shell